Okay, guys, let's do this.
Let's get into some Q&A.
Moin, I got you in the waiting room.
You're first up.
What I'm going to do before I do that, I'm going to see if there's any quick questions
I can answer on the post since those came in first.
By the way, okay, let me just start with newest or I'm going to say all comments.
Let's see what we got here.
And I appreciate you guys posting the word king on the post.
It keeps that post kind of trending towards the top and then more people can see it, okay?
Let's see if we got any quick answers real quick.
Shiju, your question is super long, which I can check out here just a second, but I'm
going to see if I can knock out any quick ones.
I don't see the link, Daniel.
Hopefully he found it.
We are live.
Did you see it?
Okay, that's the only question I see on there.
So that said, I'm going to bring Moin on.
And also, guys, if you want, you're free to put questions in the chat as well, okay?
Here comes Moin.
Okay, Moin, can you hear me, bro?
There we go.
Yeah.
What's up, dude?
Yeah, can you hear me?
I sure can.
And by the way, Luke, I think that's Luke Prichard.
You're next.
Hang in there waiting for me.
But Moin, what's your question, brother?
Moin, I can hear you clicking around like you're stealing someone's identity over there,
bro.
I know you're on.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
What's your question, dude?
Let's go.
Yeah, so, like, you know, like, my question is, like, about Google Ads.
So, like, how, you know, like, important is it in the process of, you know, of this process?
Like, does it start with Google Ads, or is there any other way to do it?
Yeah, so it's up to you, guys.
I personally prefer using Google Ads because I like to pre-sell my sites.
I like to go and get that deal up front.
However, like, there's the other way to do it, which is the traditional way.
I call it the traditional way, which is where you go, you pick a city, you pick a niche,
you rank the website, then you go and sell it.
So if you're somebody, let's say you don't have a lot of capital and you're nervous to
spend money on ads, you know, I still would argue it's better to go get the deal up front,
but maybe you're not confident in your ability to sell it, whatever, and that's what you
want to do.
That is fine.
If you want, you could start at the second half of the training, build a website, rank
it, and then go and start using the first half of the training to sell the deal.
So you can do it either way.
I just prefer going into it and getting paid while the website's ranking.
Okay, so when you're running Google ads, like, you know, like, do you do test out like three,
four sites or sites or properties, or you just run with one and then, you know, see
if it is validated or you just stop it or you continue, you know, sell it off.
So how do you start with three, four properties at the same time?
When you first start, I would recommend starting with one, but once you get going and you've
gotten that first deal, you can start adding two, and then once you figure that out, you
can start adding three.
And then what I do is once one website, one ad starts to really work, I start to get leads,
then I pause the other two and I focus on the one and so forth.
So when you first start, you probably want to start with one.
Got it?
Okay.
Let's go get a deal, brother.
You also, one thing I want to remind you of, make sure that you're focusing on asking people
for money, because no matter what you do, no matter how much content you do, no matter
how many backlinks you do, no matter how many websites you look at, unless you're asking
people for money, you're not going to make money.
Make sense?
Yeah.
So, awesome.
Well, Moin, thanks for helping out, brother.
We'll talk soon and let's go get a deal, dude.
All right.
Moin is out.
Let's get Luke in here.
Good question.
Let's see what Luke's got.
Okay, Luke, I cannot hear you.
It says it's connecting to audio.
Oh, I think it's connected.
There we go.
What's up, bro?
What's going on, Nick?
How you doing, man?
Hey, I'm about to get a hurricane up in here.
So just enjoying the sunshine.
I love that, dude.
Don't waste, you know, never, what do they say?
Never waste a good tragedy or a good opportunity like that.
Exactly.
Dude, one of my best years, 2018, I was in this niche called, I don't recommend this
niche by the way, but at the time I was in basement waterproofing and, dude, it was the
best time ever because all the basements flooded.
Yeah, I know, man.
I got a GMB for foundation repair.
I think it's going to get really active.
Oh, yeah.
A hundred percent, man.
So where are you at right now?
I'm in Jacksonville.
Beautiful.
Shout out to these hurricanes, bro.
Yeah, I know, man.
It's going to get crazy.
So, yeah, dude, what's your question, man?
So, no, honestly, the course is amazing, Digital Landlords.
I wish I'd been putting more time into it.
I'm so busy with SEO clients and they take up so much of my time.
I keep putting out fires every single day.
I just want to give a big shout out to you, but also want to ask you, would you recommend
kind of burning the boats and ditching some of these clients in order to free up more
time or do you have any recommendations for outsourcing?
So I definitely, like when I started scaling, first of all, is this, it's kind of a contextual
question because if you need it to pay the bills and it's keeping you out of your job,
then that's one thing.
But I also know that it could be the thing that's causing you not to scale because your
attention is definitely going to be split.
What I did, again, this is just from experience, is in 2020 when I started scaling is I found
a strategic partner.
I created the strategic partner.
It was my employee that was doing my SEO.
He started a company.
We did a 50-50 split.
He would sign the deal.
I'd sign the deals.
I'd send them to him.
I wouldn't talk to the client again.
He would pay me 50% of the net profit.
That allowed me to keep some of the money, but also just to focus strictly on lead generation.
So that's what I did.
It worked out really, really well.
I still was able to make about, and every time I use, I say I made 100K a month.
I hope you guys know that was just with lead gen.
This was, when I talked SEO, that was just like gravy.
We were doing like 7,000 to 12,000 a month, my split of SEO, which means I could have
taken 20 if I would have done it myself, but I just decided, I could have taken 15 to 20,
but I decided I'm going to take half of that focus on lead gen because that's where I could
actually scale.
So that's what I would recommend as far as outsourcing.
I don't really have anyone that I've used that I would recommend.
I can ask around and get that for you.
It's just difficult when you're doing white labeling because people do the bare minimum.
They just want to get paid and they don't really care, but you can shoot me a message
and maybe there's some kind of a way you could even use my team.
I don't know, but yes, if you want to send me a message, I'm happy to do that, man.
All right, man.
You have a good one.
Bro, appreciate you hopping on.
Hey, good luck with the hurricane.
If you could, get us some good photos for the websites, dude.
Let's get some storm damage.
Yeah, maybe.
That's a good one.
All right.
I'll try my best.
Hey, good to talk to you, man.
We'll talk soon.
Later, Nick.
See you, my boy.
Okay, guys, good questions so far.
Let's see if I got anything else cooking in the chat.
Okay, let's see.
What else?
I'm going to go to Robert really quick.
Robert said he's got clicks, but no phone calls.
Can you assist?
One thing I would love to just try and just reiterate that something that I've tried to
really focus on is try to just, whenever you have an issue in your business, try to just
use your intuition and think, okay, and by the way, this goes for anything.
If your business owners aren't closing, but you're getting a bunch of people to a closing
call, then you could use the same exact logic, okay?
But with this situation, you're like, okay, I'm getting clicks, but no phone calls.
That means that people are clicking on my ads and I'm getting no phone calls.
Well, then you start kind of digging deeper, you go, all right, well, assuming that these
people are visiting my website, then that would mean that I'm either getting the wrong
people to my website because they're not ready to buy, they're not ready to call for an estimate,
so that could be number one.
The other thing is I have the right people, but my landing page isn't converting, right?
So that's what you have to look at and you have to kind of be logical about it, okay?
So what I would recommend is there's a couple of different things that you can do.
If you have an idea that maybe your website's not converting, you can go, there's a software
called Hotjar, you can install Hotjar on your, and there's other ones too, but you can install
Hotjar on your website, you can track and look at what people, you know, when they come
to the page, what are they doing, are they scrolling below the fold, are they doing this,
are they doing that, whatever.
So that's an idea.
If you think it's a conversion issue, if you think it's maybe the wrong type of customer
or you think they're clicking on the ad and they're not going to the website, for example,
I know sometimes I used to think it was my competitors, maybe you could go and you could
track, you could set up your analytics, you could see, are you getting, you know, how
much traffic are you actually getting?
Is it increasing?
Is it lining up with how many clicks you're getting?
And you just kind of have to dissect it from there and you just have to do a process of
elimination.
But if you guys are using the core keywords, you guys are following the training, most
likely you have the right traffic going to your website, which means that you have a
conversion issue, which then I would go, hey, is your website, you know, something that's
actually converting, is it user friendly?
Is it something that is scaring people off?
Is the number easy to find?
Is the quote form easy to find?
Or are you burying the stuff at the bottom, making it difficult?
So you just kind of have to use your intuition there.
Go look at some of our example websites.
You could go look at BentonvilleConcrete.com.
It doesn't have to be complicated.
It's very simple.
I promise you guys, even the ugly websites convert.
So that's kind of how I would attack that.
But that's a really good question, Robert.
OK, Luke, you might have had another question.
He's back in the waiting room.
Oh, shoot, hold on.
I think I might have just jumped him in there again.
Hey, did you?
Oh, he's out.
OK, I thought he had another question.
I was like, OK, boy.
Anyway, all right, let's keep going along.
Guys, any questions you have, drop them in the chat.
If you would like, you can you can grab the link.
I'm going to actually pin that comment so you can join with that link above.
You guys are just hopping on and you want to click on the Zoom.
Guys, I'm not that scary.
I promise you, I'm a complete goof.
If you guys, I know when I've I used to get on these live calls and I
was like, oh, my gosh, I can't imagine getting on live with the person.
It's not that big of a deal.
Just hop on live.
And, you know, let's ask your question.
It's going to be quicker.
All right.
Linnell says Google Keyword Planner says,
before I say this, I want to let you guys know something that's kind of exciting
because this is an ads question.
We actually this is this is why I love that I'm in the trenches, that I'm in the game,
that I think that you cannot trust anyone that's not, is because things change
so freaking much with this business, with any business.
I don't know how you could be in the business five years ago, 10 years ago,
eight years ago, like when I started or maybe four years ago
when I made my first million and pretend like I know everything.
Right. If I wasn't in the game, then I wouldn't have any idea
what you guys are talking about.
So what I want to let you guys know is we are in the process of once again,
testing out some new ad strategies, testing out some new
campaign strategies, spending my own money, testing it on my websites.
We've been doing this now.
It's been about five weeks, I believe.
And we're going to run it for another three weeks, making it eight weeks total.
And then we are going to be redoing the training for the ad section.
And I hate to even tell you guys this, because then everyone's
going to start asking when's it going to be done, when's it going to be done.
It's not going to be done probably till Q1 of 2025,
but we are actually going to be redoing the entire training
start to finish, which would make it the third version of this training
since we launched. OK, I'm actually really excited about it.
I'm a little bit nervous and intimidated by how big of a project that is.
But I also want to always be giving you guys relevant information.
And so any of those little tiny changes, it's kind of like when you have the books
and it's like the classic Think and Grow Rich and it says,
this is the 24th edition, right?
Just those minor things that change with the times.
So a lot of these things, I'm telling you this because once we launch
and what I'm going to do is before we actually launch,
I'm not going to wait to give you guys the the ads updates.
And we're going to introduce the ads updates as soon as possible.
And then for like two or three weeks, we're going to be doing Q&A on these calls.
So any of these questions, we're going to give you guys, you know,
the the the exact answers, maybe even show you guys live on screen.
So I just want to let you know that.
But let me look at this question says Google Keyword Planner says high end CPC.
By the way, Linnell, I don't know if you knew this already.
Have you checked out Ryan Dalton's
rank and rent engine? OK, because that is going to be our go to tool.
I should have mentioned this at the beginning.
But that's going to be our go to tool for search volume.
That's going to be our go to tool for due diligence.
That's going to be our go to tool for everything.
If you guys did not see that already, I think I can message Ryan right now.
Let me look. But there we were doing a
I'm going to drop the link really quick.
We were doing a link. I'm sorry, not a link.
We were doing a beta discount for anyone that wanted to check that out.
So I'm actually going to put this on your comments.
And I'm only mentioning this because that's going to be our go to on
the search volume and the due diligence and everything else.
OK, so check that out.
I can't even remember what the code was.
You have to look at the last one.
There's a code that you guys can use that will
maybe I should message Ryan really quick.
Hold on. Let me message him while we're waiting.
We just ask him, Ryan Dalton,
what's the discount code for beta users?
OK, anyway, guys, check that out.
The thing is sick. I'm pumped about it.
I'm actually going to be spending about 90 minutes today just playing around with it.
But anyway, it says high end CPC is five dollars with the clicks
I'm getting are saying twelve dollars.
It's in tree service.
Is it because the time of year less?
Lonell, can you do a favor for me?
Just make a quick loom.
Send me what you're getting or send it to me and send it to fix it.
Paid ads as well.
And we'll check that out because that's a bit more of a deep question.
And we'll dissect figure out what the heck's going on. OK.
Simon says, oh, what's going on, dude?
Luke says, we're in the meeting again.
Why are you reading this people just join the program?
Luke, Luke, Luke. OK.
OK, Simon has an interesting question.
He says, what do you think about Ecom with the digital asset approach?
Can he do it?
Guys, my answer to this is whether you're asking me about, you know,
whole barns, whether you're asking me about assisted living leads,
if you ask me about whatever, if you use this strategy,
which is getting paid traffic or organic traffic to a landing page
or to a website, you are going to get leads or conversions.
Because if you sell a product, the same principles apply.
However, the thing that makes this model so special
is the fact that we can use a generic website.
And we if if let's say our client starts to get sideways on us,
they start to get a little funny, they start to complain.
We can sell those leads to somebody else.
So if you do Ecom, let's say you go to a company and they're like,
hey, I want you to sell these water filters for us. Right.
And you're doing all this SEO for these water filters.
That's great.
But first of all, first of foremost, you're probably going to be doing SEO
on like a national level, which makes it very difficult.
It's going to be much more difficult to get SEO
to rank using SEO to get organic rankings.
The other thing, guys, is that company is kind of going to have you buy the balls.
Right. Because if you're advertising their products
and you're using their branding or their location or their specific
keywords that they want to target, what happens if they don't want to buy leads anymore?
So you have to remember that one of the best parts about this business model
is the ability to have complete control over our assets
and not have to be at the mercy of anybody.
And this kind of defeats the purpose of it.
So could it work? Yes. Do I recommend it? No.
If it's your own brand and it's your own ecom products,
your own ecom store, your own products, then OK, fine.
Use the SEO principles in the second half of the training to get your website ranked.
But to do it for somebody else, I don't think it's the move. OK.
There goes Luke Hill with the discount code ignition 24. Great.
Thank you. I'm going to try and.
Oh, he already did it. Thank you.
Beautiful. OK. Robert says hot jar.
Wow. Thank you. Yes. Hot jar. Great tool.
OK. I got somebody the waiting room.
I'm going to jump to them really quick.
And then I've got one or two more questions.
By the way, Simon said it's his own website.
Yeah, Simon, use the SEO.
Use the SEO strategies in the training for sure.
If it's your own website, absolutely. OK, 100 percent.
But just realize that that changes the model a bit.
Now you're just doing SEO for your own website, right?
OK, let's see what we got here.
SD. I have no idea.
I'm guessing who's SD, who's got the initial SD. SD.
I can see that you're connected to audio.
I just can't hear you. I can't see you.
Let me know if you can hear me. You can see me.
OK, not hearing anything.
Don't know what's going on.
Let's see what we got. OK.
Well, that person is figuring out what's going on.
I'm going to keep going.
OK, Rob Lamb says, what social media accounts do you create
like Facebook business page, Instagram page, Yelp
to increase your chance of getting a GMB as part of creating a new city niche account?
In other words, what are things you do to help improve Google acceptance?
Guys, I don't spend a bunch of time with GMB anymore, OK,
because to me, can you?
Yes. Is it still possible? Yes.
Did we actually recently got a GMB like in the last two weeks
trying some new strategies, but I have not found anything that's tried and true
that I'm confident saying, hey, here's the new strategy.
What I've kind of opted to do instead is that I am going to focus
on getting better at ads and getting better at organic rankings faster.
OK, because guys, think about it like this.
I've said this before, but you got to realize that when we have
with Google, right, you can get leads from paid ads,
you can get leads from the Google My Business or the local
and you can get leads from organic.
And if you can get two of those three, you're going to be just fine.
Back in 2020, when I was just trying to figure things out
on more than half of my website or at least half of my websites,
I didn't even have a GMB because it didn't click to me.
It didn't occur to me that I could use the business owner's address.
I didn't understand all the stuff.
And so I was going along getting deals scaling up to one hundred
thousand dollars a month, not realizing that I even needed a GMB.
You don't need a GMB.
Now, if you can get one, does it help? Sure.
But even if I have them, I don't like to rely on them for leads
because I feel like they're always problems.
You're falling off. You're doing this.
You're getting suspended. You're checking, checking, checking.
So for me, I just decided, you know what?
I'm going to focus on getting better at the things that I know how to do,
which is ads and organic.
And if we can get the GMB grade, if we can't, then whatever.
However, I will tell you that, yes, the Facebook business page does help.
The Yelp page does help.
But me personally, I'm just focusing on I told you that I'm in simplification mode.
I mean, hey, these are the things I know that work.
So I'm going to focus on them.
And so that's what I've tried to put my effort on.
That doesn't mean you can't.
Doesn't mean that's not a possibility, but that's where I'm putting my focus. OK.
What else we got here?
So hopefully, oh, there we go. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
OK, can you hear me, SD?
Yeah, I can hear you. It's actually should do Daniel.
Oh, what's up, bro? How are you?
Hey, good. This will be good.
Find your question, because I saw your question on the other one.
And I know to be very honest, I saw it and I was like, it's kind of long.
I'll come back to it.
And I'm glad you hopped on it because I forgot to go back to it.
So ask me your question.
All right. So I'm having a tough time figuring out if I'm picking the right guy.
So I just went back to the keywords that you created.
OK, so I'm doing like a ton of analysis.
Maybe I'm doing too much.
I'm analyzing like 26 here because I wrote it.
I'm a programmer, so I wrote an app to do all this for me.
I'm not doing it manually.
So I'm running like 26 keywords per city.
And that's the screenshots I put in.
So am I doing too much?
Like, how do I know if those cities I pasted in are actually good?
Yeah, I think you're doing too much.
I mean, dude, look, I think you're doing too much.
Look, I think people like you are I swear to you.
And I mean this and I mean this as a compliment.
You guys are too smart.
Like the reason why this model works really well for people like me is because I'm like,
all right, I don't even have the patience to do more than like five or seven.
I don't think you need more than five or seven keywords to analyze the city.
OK, all right. So the second part was, I mean, let me say one last thing.
So like tree service, I know that the lists are in here.
I can I can share those two.
And guys, if you guys have lists or you've seen lists I've shared in the past,
that would be awesome for you guys to reshare those.
I can also go and find them.
But tree service, you're looking at at least concrete, because it's just the one
that was used. So concrete is the core keyword.
They got concrete contractors.
I think concrete company, concrete patio, concrete driveway, concrete sidewalk.
There might be one more.
I'm going to use those keywords plus the city.
And that's going to be enough for me to say yes or no on a city.
That's part one. What's part two?
Part two was.
I can't remember right now, so it should I split out the ads like for
let's say I do three ads for concrete, like one is driveway, one is cement,
one is patio. Should I do it all in one or split it into three?
So repeat that question again.
So you're saying split the budget into three.
Yeah, or make three separate ads.
Separate ads like do only one ad that concentrates on cement keywords.
Do another ad that only concentrates on patio keywords.
You know what? That's a really good question.
I don't want to give you guys I would not want to give you advice that.
And I said this at the beginning of the call, I this would be a question
I would I would much rather fix it paid ads answer.
What I would want you to do on this question, and I don't know if you caught this,
but we're actually redoing again the training on the ads and then
and also the entire training.
But for this specific question, I think this is this be valuable for everybody.
If you would post that just that simple question, say, you know, whatever,
post that in the group.
And then if you want to go a step further, make a quick little loom
and send it to me and fix it paid ads, I'll give you an in-depth answer.
But I don't want to just shoot something off the hip.
So would you do that for me?
Yeah, I'll definitely do that.
The only reason I ask is because when you have targeted keywords for that ad,
you get to, you know, you get to that 100 percent.
You know how good the ad is.
You know, you get poor, good and excellent.
If it's all related, like you get closer to the excellent faster.
That's why my my knee jerk reaction is I would tell you to do a separate ad
for each, because, yes, that that is the relevancy that that's really going to help.
And we've noticed that's been a big thing
with the way that we're doing ads now.
However, I also don't want to, you know, if there's somebody out there
that's listening to this and they hear that, oh, three ads,
I would rather you just get them up than not get them up at all.
So if that's causing analysis, paralysis, no.
But yes, 100 percent what you're saying, I think that is going to be the answer.
But I would love for you to post that.
Let's get everyone's feedback.
I'll get fix it paid ads in there and then keep an eye out for this
updated training, which we're about five five out of eight weeks into the testing of.
All right. Sounds good.
I think I got all my questions out of the way.
Awesome, man. Well, I appreciate it.
And let's go get some deals, dude. Thanks a lot.
Hey, talk to you, man.
OK, guys, there's another question or two I want to answer.
You guys have really good questions.
I've got a question is what do you guys use for phone numbers?
I'm going to drop the rank and rent engine
link because that is where we are now buying all of our phone numbers.
However, another option is call rail.
But it's a little more expensive.
That's what we started by using. OK, so there you go.
Hopefully that answers your question.
Luke said, if you throw up a GMB as well for Ecom, it can be a moneymaker.
I've done it before, but that's for more.
Yeah. And that's a good point, Luke, is if this is for your own Ecom,
you're going to be able to get if it's a legit brand, a legit company,
you should be able to get your GMB much easier.
So that's a great little nugget you tossed in there.
OK, Simon says, do you have a list where one can see the key
services by country, if not, that would be really handy for all of us.
Post that in the group. Great question.
And I think what he's saying is like, what are the recommended
services in each country?
And I think that that would be the the the people that are most
equipped to answer those questions would be the people in those countries.
OK, so I'm not doing any deals in Australia.
I'm not doing any deals in the UK personally,
because I'm making my money here.
It makes no sense for me to do that other than probably just a test,
which I probably should.
But drop that question, guys.
We have a we have a community of 700 people trying to do this.
You guys don't have to be on an island by yourselves.
Amazing questions.
Drop that question if you would in the group.
And let's see if anybody has recommendations.
However, I do know just off top my head,
tree service seems to be something that is valuable in every single country.
I've seen that in every single question.
I'm going to I'm going to stand by that one.
That one seems to be like a pretty good one in every single country
from what I could tell. OK.
Steven says you can also decline the recommendations and it will push you up
to 100 percent. Amazing. Great feedback. OK.
Gina says, are you going to do more training on the RankinRat engine platform?
Yes, we are.
We didn't. We wanted to just introduce it really quick
and then let everybody play with it.
And we guys, by the way, if you guys are interested in
if you guys are using that product,
please give feedback to Ryan so we can improve it.
We've noticed a few tiny little bugs as we've been testing with our team.
But that's to be expected. It's beta test.
It's pretty damn good for being a beta test.
But please give feedback to Ryan.
Send him an email. Send him a direct message. Do both.
And yeah, let's just play around with that.
Let's make that thing the I mean, if you guys give us feedback, we can
we can go and I can tell Ryan, hey, let's change this.
Let's change this. I'm super excited about that.
But yes, we're going to be doing that the first week of November
when we do our official launch.
We'll be doing way more training.
But that was kind of just like a hey, let's let let's let people
in the community test this out first.
But there will be a significant amount more.
Plus, there is a Facebook group.
I don't know if you're part of that yet, Gina.
Maybe I'll put this in the answer, but I'm going to say join
the Facebook group.
The rank and rent engine Facebook group.
Yes. OK, so a lot, a lot more to come as far as that training.
That's going to be integrated in everything that we do.
Case. OK, Robert says we got one or two more questions here.
Robert says, Nick, do you try to sign first to be all
that is on top of the sponsored ad section?
Do you check there?
I don't I don't really care if they're at the top or not.
As long as they're running ads, they're going on my list.
But yeah, I mean, checking their reviews is not a bad thing.
If I'm looking at the reviews, they're like, oh, this guy is rude.
This guy had no customer service.
That's going to be my partner.
And that means they're probably not going to close deals.
That's going to be an issue. I want to check into all those things.
So Robert, check into those things.
But yeah, anyone at the top is going on my list.
That's part of our training or part of our module and
building your list.
So, yes. OK, Simon says he volunteers for Middle East and Armenia.
Amazing. Go ahead and make that post and then give us your recommended niches.
You recommend industries for Armenia.
OK, Gina says I'm loving it and have some feedback for sure.
Yes, that's great. Maybe we'll even do something midweek.
Gina, I will even have a pen here. Yeah, I do.
I'm going to make a note here.
Maybe we'll go live, me and Ryan, and we'll just do some more training
and answer questions and get feedback.
That's a great idea, actually. I just wrote it down.
OK, no problem on the questions.
OK, what else? I have time for one more. Let's see.
OK, Rankinret engine says I couldn't use some of my unique niches.
OK, I don't know exactly what you're saying, but that is great feedback.
Would you send that feedback to Ryan?
Just send him a direct message and tell him which niches you're talking about.
Maybe that's just a glitch and let's get that feedback.
That's really good feedback.
Hey, Simon says, how can we measure market saturation for digital assets?
That's I might need you to give a little bit more information on that.
Maybe you can and I can answer it on a on a comment.
But guys, I'm telling you, those of you guys that are worried about saturation,
we are there. Go watch my videos.
Type in saturation. Is Rankinret saturated on YouTube?
And go listen to my logical answers, OK?
This is not saturated.
And just because you guys are seeing other Rankinret people,
other marketers does not mean it's saturated.
Just because there's someone else the website doesn't mean you can't have one.
Just because there's somebody else that, you know, sorry,
just because there is somebody that has a website in your niche and city
does not mean they even have a client.
It doesn't even mean that they're even in the business anymore.
It doesn't mean that they know how to sell and create a deal.
You guys have to remember that those websites that you guys see
and get so scared of, they are just like another local business.
OK, don't worry about that. Keep going. OK.
OK, guys, got a ton of so many good questions.
I mean, here's what I'm going to do. I'm either going to roll it.
I'm going to try to either answer these on comments, me or Aaron
or fix it, fix it, Felix.
Or I'm going to create YouTube videos out of these questions
and I'll send you guys a link to these guys.
I really love you guys hopping on.
I hope next time we have even more people.
It's fun to connect with you guys, to to hear your voices,
see your faces, to remember that like we're all in this together.
We're all trying to make money.
We're all trying to create better lives for ourselves.
So, guys, let's go make some money.
Don't forget that you're not making money if you're not asking for money.
OK, no matter how many of these questions we talk about, you know,
we, you know, as this keywords that at the end of the day,
it's about how many offers we make.
That's how you make money.
Stop being distracted.
Go ask people for money and let's scale this thing up, guys.
I'll see you guys later in the week, hopefully with Ryan.
If not, I'll see you guys next Tuesday.
I'm out.